gráfica los siguientes números en la
recta numérica que tenemos por aquí al 5
y es muy fácil graficar lo ósea son 5
lugares a la derecha del 0 y es por aquí
entonces ahora vamos a graficar un
tercio y bueno para graficar un tercio
incluso podemos agarrar este pedazo que
es del 0 al 1 y dividirlo en tres partes
iguales aunque hoy por aquí está una
tercio por aquí está dos tercios y por
aquí estaría tres tercios pero tres
tercios es igual a uno entonces un
tercio lo encontramos dividiendo en tres
pedazos este segmento de recta numérica
así es que un tercio está por aquí
déjame lo escribo
tercio y bueno entonces vamos con menos
1.2 que podemos empezar por encontrar
menos uno está por aquí pero menos 1.2
está más hacia la izquierda que menos 1
ok tenemos que llegar al menos 1 y luego
poner menos punto 2 eso está como por
aquí hey menos 1.2 y ahora encontrar al
cero es súper sencillo está allí podemos
ahora continuar con menos dos y un
cuarto entonces que tenemos que hacer
tenemos que irnos a menos todos y a eso
sumarle menos un cuarto aunque entonces
tenemos que dividir este segmento del -2
al menos tres en cuatro partes iguales
aquí está dividido en cuatro pedazos y
al menos dos que es este punto le
tenemos que sumar menos un cuarto o sea
tenemos que irnos hasta acá
por aquí está menos dos y un cuarto y
finalmente 4.1 nos vamos al 4 y tenemos
que sumarle punto 1 entonces en realidad
nos va a quedar 4.1 por acá 4.1